inicio en la bretaña francesa la primera
cumbre internacional de alto nivel
exclusivamente dedicada a las aguas que
cubren el 70% de la superficie de
nuestro planeta que curiosamente se
llama tierra el objetivo de estos tres
días es alcanzar compromisos que
protejan al océano frente por ejemplo la
pesca ilegal la sobrepesca la
contaminación plástica o la amenaza de
exploración y explotación del fondo
marino para la obtención de minerales
uno de los mayores retos será el de
conseguir un acuerdo de gobernanza de
las aguas que no formen parte de los
territorios exclusivos de cada país y
por lo tanto no estén reguladas por
leyes nacionales y poder así aumentar la
protección de los ecosistemas marinos a
un 30 por ciento antes del 2030 una
cifra que ahora mismo está en un tan
solo 7%
recordemos que el océano es el verdadero
pulmón de la tierra ya que absorbe el 25
por ciento de las emisiones de co2
mundial y regula los patrones climáticos
mundiales y además 3 mil millones de
personas en el mundo dependen de él para
su subsistencia aunque durante la cumbre
con 26 celebrada en glasgow del año
pasado se integraba por fin al océano en
el texto final bajo el amparo del marco
convención de la onu contra el cambio
climático los expertos aseguran que hay
mucho por hacer antes de esta con 27 que
se celebra por cierto en una ciudad
costera de egipto